a woman cannot be masculine she can be
pseudo masculine man can be masculine
you're insane of course you can't be
masculine because when she said what are
you gonna do if I actually got up and
then she said oh what you can and the
reason I'm just trying to say is no man
would do that because I would get up and
do something sure and the thing about
this is this is what I'm trying to say
whoever raised her Scott's an upbringing
because Scott's not bringing you
disgusting not bring him I'd love to
watch it disgusting
I'm a podcaster I'm a podcaster I've got
no money here I ain't got no money she's
not only fans though
I'm talking more money than him that's
the problem